ich eröffne die Aussprache und das Wort
hat zuerst für die FDP-Fraktion Otto
Fricke
der Frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen worum geht es
heute auf den einfachen Weg hin könnte
man sagen es geht um 200 Milliarden das
ist aber eine einfache Antwort denn es
geht um etwas anderes und es geht um
etwas was für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und für die Unternehmen wichtig ist
nämlich die Einhaltung des Versprechens
dass die Ampelkoalition noch vor dem
Winter dafür sorgt dass ausreichende
Finanzmittel sowohl in der Heizperiode
2223 als auch in der Heizperiode 23 24
und ausreichende Mittel für Gas und
Strom für Unternehmen und Bürger
vorhanden sein werden dieses Versprechen
was die Koalition gegeben hat löst sie
mit diesem Gesetzentwurf ein
und bevor sich die cdu/csu wieder
aufregt gebe ich noch mal den Hinweis
darauf dass wir mit diesem Gesetz mit
diesen 200 Milliarden die
Voraussetzungen dafür schaffen dass die
Finanzmittel jederzeit zur Verfügung
stehen wir haben eine gaskommission die
uns in sehr kluger Weise gesagt hat ihr
müsst ganz wesentlich zwei Dinge tun ihr
müsst an einer Stelle sofort helfen und
da sage ich auch allen ja das wird bei
Soforthilfen nicht 100% gerecht sein wer
hundertprozentige Gerechtigkeit mein
Versprechen zu können der versucht den
Einzelfall bis zum infinitum zu regeln
und der wird am Ende nicht dafür sorgen
dass dem einzelnen Bürger dem einzelnen
Unternehmer dem berühmten Bäcker
geholfen wird das machen wir dadurch
dass wir im Dezember bereits
entsprechende Zahlungen ermöglichen
zweitens und das ist sehr sehr wichtig
wir zeigen auch auf dass die Mittel dann
auch im Jahre 23 bereits vorhanden sind
und wir jederzeit auf sie zurückgreifen
können und ich möchte hier auch noch mal
in Richtung cdu/csu sagen das ist keine
reine buchhaltungsverschiebung sondern
wie wir ja zum Staunen der cdu/csu im
Haushaltsausschuss feststellen können es
sind tatsächliche Bewegungen die dafür
sorgen dass die entsprechenden Papiere
auch beim Wirtschaft und
stabilisierungsfond liegen jederzeit
genutzt werden können und meine Damen
und Herren wir sorgen damit dafür dass
wir bei der gaspreisbremse
strompreisbremse den Stützungsmaßnahmen
für die Unternehmen und auch bei
Härtefällen jederzeit die ausreichende
Mittel haben das ist die Verantwortung
dieser Ampelkoalition und die nimmt sie
dann auch wahr und das möchte ich dann
auch deutlich sagen es ist genau wieder
die Trias dieser Koalition die erfüllt
wird wir sorgen auf der einen Seite
neben dieser Regelung mit anderen
Sozialgesetzen dafür dass die
schwächsten unserer Gesellschaft
geschützt werden und nehmen unseren
soziale Verantwortung wahr wir sorgen
gleichzeitig aber auch dafür dass wir
bei der Frage des Anreizes wie viel
gegeben wird ökologisch denken und dafür
sorgen dass die Frage zu sparen auch ein
Teil dieses Systems ist und es nicht
einfach nur ist Hauptsache jeder hat
genug Geld und es wird einfach geheizt
sondern dafür zu sorgen dass
Nachhaltigkeit Teil von Hilfe ist auch
das ist Teil dieser Koalition und
drittens das halte ich für sehr wichtig
Bürger aber noch mehr Unternehmen
bekommen Planungssicherheit und hier
nochmal meine inständige Bitte an die
cdu/csu erinnern Sie sich doch einmal
daran was sie vor einem Monat dieser
Koalition noch gesagt haben ihren wacht
nichts ihr lasst die Bürger im Stich ihr
besorgt kein Geld ihr müsst um Hunderte
von Milliarden haben wo sind die ich
kann Ihnen das ganz genau sagen hier
sind diese 200 Milliarden und sie haben
die Möglichkeit hier an der Stelle dann
auch zuzustimmen meine Damen und Herren
ich gehe auch gerne auf die Kritik des
Rechnungshofes sein
ich glaube ohne den Rechnungshof würde
einen Teil von Jackson balances in
unserer Demokratie fehlen aber dennoch
ist ein Bundesrechnungshof nicht
unfehlbar und das haben wir dann uns ja
auch angehört gestern an der Stelle ja
dass die Linken da besonders klatschen
ist mir auch klar bei der Aussage aber
wir mussten feststellen dass der
Rechnungshof selber sagte dass er die
Frage wie die Finanzierung der 200
Milliarden erfolgt noch gar nicht
geprüft hat er gab sogar zu dass es
sachliche Zusammenhänge über die Jahre
gibt konnte aber an der Stelle dann auch
nicht sagen wie die Lösungen im
eigentlichen wäre und das möchte ich
dann deutlich sagen ja Haushalte sind in
Jährlichkeit und ich bin sicher ein
Mittelberg wird das nachher wieder alles
irgendwo versuchen zu skandalisieren
aber ich will in eines deutlich zum
Thema Jährlichkeit sagen eine Fraktion
die selber viele Sondervermögen mit
guten Gründen den wir als FDP in der
Position auch in Teilen zugestimmt haben
immer wieder Sondervermögen in den
Fällen macht wo sie übrigens von der
Verfassung auch vorgesehen sind die
Verfassung verbietet keine
Sondervermögen da ist es dann auch
notwendig zu prüfen machen wir es mit
einem Sondervermögen und das sage ich
deutlich wenn die cdu/csu sagt wir
wollen keine Sondervermögen dann frage
ich mich hätten sie bei den Opfern im
Aartal gesagt ach übrigens ob ihr im
nächsten Jahr noch Geld kriegt das
können wir euch noch nicht sagen das
können wir euch erst im November sagen
wenn wir den Haushalt für das nächste
Jahr beschließen ob ihr bei der
Bundeswehr Investitionen machen könnt
das können wir euch gegen Ende des
Jahres erst sagen wir machen das nicht
nein auch da sie machen einen
Sondervermögen ja ich gestehe zu sie
ändern sogar sie sind sogar bereit für
Sondervermögen die Verfassung zu ändern
und dann sage ich ihnen zu dem und das
erwarte ich dann auch wenn jetzt von der
cdu/csu wenn Sie hier berechtigt im
Namen ihrer oppositionsaufgabe das
kritisiert etwas zu tun was sie bisher
in Haushalt und finanzdebatten nicht tut
nämlich wirklich ihre alternative
durchgerechnet dazu legen und nicht
einfach zu sagen Alternativen ist nicht
unsere Aufgabe eigentlich zu meinen
Alternativen darlegen können wir
eigentlich gar nicht das ist ihr Problem
und da müssen sie sich dran messen
lassen in den nächsten Minuten hier im
Plenum meine Damen und Herren ich will
es deswegen ganz deutlich sagen mehr
Parlamentsrechte ein wir sorgen für
Kontrollen wir sorgen an ganz vielen
Stellen dafür dass dieses Parlament sehr
genau dafür sorgen wird dass nach diesen
200 Milliarden in den nächsten Wochen
die umsetzungsgesetze kommen mit
Parlamentsbeteiligung beteiligen sie
sich dann und bitte machen Sie endlich
mal Vorschläge die konkret
durchgerichtet sind und nicht einfach
nur pure simple Oppositionen dafür ist
die Sache zu ernst herzlichen Dank
Otto Fricke der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion hat die
Debatte eröffnet die abschließende
Beratung über das
stabilisierungsfondsgesetz und
es geht um nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als die 200 Milliarden Euro die als
Abwehrschirm dienen sollen meine Damen
und Herren um das gleich klarzustellen
wir wollen auch ein Schutzschirm für die
Menschen und für die Betriebe in unserem
Land in dieser Krise um das ganz
klarzustellen das Problem ist aber heute
geht es gar nicht um diesen Schutzschirm
heute geht es auch nicht um
gaspreisbremse strompreisbremse und
unternehmenshilfen da steht hier heute
gar nicht zur Debatte der steht auch
nicht zur Entscheidung heute steht zur
Entscheidung und der widerspreche ich
Ihnen ausdrücklicher Fricke weil sie
haben versucht das genau andersrum
darzustellen heute steht einfach zu
Entscheidung dass Sie von uns einen
Geldsack haben wollen gefüllt mit 200
Milliarden Euro und den wollen sie sich
dann in den Keller ihrer Regierung
stellen und dann wollen sie überlegen
und dann wollen sie überlegen was sie
mit dem Geld anfangen das ist die
Wirklichkeit
das ist die Wahrheit
[Applaus]
ich sage Ihnen ja die Wirklichkeit ist
dass wir kein konkreten Vorschlag haben
für ihre gaspreisbremse wir haben bisher
nur ein Kommissionsvorschlag den
Vorschlag den die Kommission entwickelt
hat den haben wir schon vor anderthalb
Monaten auf unserem Bundesparteitag
beschlossen das ist das Thema für ihre
strompreisbremse liegt nichts Konkretes
vor und für die unternehmenshilfen liegt
nichts Konkretes vor sie verlangen von
uns dass wir Alternativen rechnen sollen
wir würden gerne rechnen aber dann
müssten wir von Ihnen eine
Berechnungsgrundlage kriegen was wollen
Sie denn machen kein Mensch in diesem
Land weiß was sie konkret machen
nein das Gegenteil ist doch richtig wie
sie zu recht sagen die Menschen in
diesem Land sind in größten Sorgen
teilweise in Angst weil sie nicht wissen
ob sie die Abschläge an ihren
Energieversorger bezahlen können die
Betriebe in diesem Land können nicht
planen und können nicht rechnen sie
können keine Investition tätigen keine
Bestellung sie wissen nicht ob Sie einen
Auftrag im nächsten Jahr annehmen können
weil sie nicht wissen mit welchen
Energiepreisen sie ihre Produktion
kalkulieren können Sie wissen gar nicht
ob sie wettbewerbsfähig anbieten können
in dieser Unsicherheit warten die
Menschen auf diese Regierung die heute
im übrigen ja gar nicht anwesend ist
sämtliche mit Minister sind weggelaufen
wir entscheiden heute über 200
Milliarden die sie bewilligt haben
wollen und wir sehen kein vorhandenen
gegen Frau stark wachsen hervorragend
aber keiner der Ressortminister keiner
der irgendwie zuständigen Minister ist
heute da das an sich ist schon ein
Skandal
die Menschen in diesem Land
warten darauf dass diese Regierung
endlich handelt aber sie tut es nicht
sie beschäftigen sich permanent mit sich
selbst und ihren internen Streitereien
den ganzen Sommer über haben sie
verplempert mit internen Streit im Juli
haben sie uns eine gasumlage eine
zusätzliche Belastung der Verbraucher
vorgeschlagen zwei Monate hat Herr
Habeck gebraucht um diesen Fehler zu
korrigieren und ungenügend und das sage
ich ganz deutlich ist ihre
Regierungshandeln auch beim Thema wie
steigern wir das Angebot bei Strom und
Gas ihr fauler Kompromiss zu den
Kernkraftwerken mag über dieses über
diesen Winter hinweg retten im nächsten
Winter hilft er ganz sicher nicht und
die Frau Grimm die Wirtschaftsweise
dieselbe Wirtschaftsweise die den
Vorschlag für die gaspreisbremse
ausgerechnet hat den sie ja so toll
finden hat ihnen auch vorgerechnet dass
wenn Sie die drei Kernkraftwerke weiter
betreiben bis Ende 24 dann würde der
Strompreis um bis zu zwölf Prozent
billiger werden wenn die Menschen in
diesem Land im nächsten Jahr zwölf
Prozent mehr für ihren Strompreis zahlen
dann haben sie das dem Frieden in dieser
Ampel und der Grünen Ideologie zu
verdanken das ist die Wirklichkeit
so
und jetzt sage ich ihnen zu dem Thema
Finanzierung wir würden sie bei ihrem
Schutzschirm wirklich gerne unterstützen
und das ist ehrlich gemeint es geht
nicht darum dass diese Opposition sich
eine Unterstützung verweigert aber ich
sage es nochmal wir würden dann von
ihnen auch wenigstens mal ein konkretes
Konzept für die gaspreisbremse für die
strompreisbremse und eine Berechnung für
die unternehmenshilfen auf den Tisch
stehen die könnten wir dann prüfen damit
können wir uns auseinandersetzen wie
normale Menschen die überlegen doch auch
erst was kaufe ich mir was kostet und
dann gehen sie zur Bank und holen sich
das Geld und sie erklären uns hier ist
wer logisch wenn man es genau umgekehrt
machen würde nein es ist schwachsinn was
sie machen und das ist nicht zu
begründen
sie wissen nicht wofür sie das Geld
brauchen sie wissen nicht wann sie das
Geld brauchen und trotzdem wollen Sie
von uns eine Blanco Zusage über 200
Milliarden das kann man doch gar nicht
das kann man gar nicht gutheißen das ist
unmöglich
ihre Finanzierungsmethode ist maximal
unsolide und das hat ihnen auch der
Bundesrechnungshof in dieser Woche
vorgehalten der ihnen erklärt hat dass
es verfassungsrechtlich ausgesprochen
fragwürdig ist was sie machen sie wollen
jetzt
sie wollen sich jetzt 200 Milliarden
Euro in den Keller legen wollen alle
diese Kredite auf dieses Jahr rechnen
damit dann ihr Finanzminister der ja
versprochen hat dass er die
Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr einhält
damit der dann sagen kann weil er jetzt
die Taschen voller Geld hat damit er
dann künstlich sagen kann im nächsten
Jahr ich halte die Schuldenbremse ein
das ist ein schlichtes Umgehungsmanöver
und nichts anderes
ehrlich wäre
ehrlich wäre wenn wir in diesem Jahr
einen Nachtragshaushalt beraten und
verabschieden würden und da werden wir
es völlig okay wenn Sie den jetzt
arbeiten und vorlegen und im nächsten
Jahr machen wir das oder für das nächste
Jahr machen wir es im regulären
Haushaltsverfahren dann sagen Sie wie
viel Geld sie zu welchen Zwecken
brauchen wann sie es brauchen dann sagen
Sie bitte auch an welchen Stellen im
Haushalt Sie einsparen wollen da haben
sie bisher überhaupt nichts auf die
Leiste gebracht obwohl sich in ihrem
eigenen Koalitionsvertrag versprochen
haben dann würden wir gerne eine
Berechnung der Mehreinnahmen sehen die
nämlich wegen der gestiegenen Preise
gewaltig sind am meisten verdient daran
der Finanzminister
dann haben sie Spielraum in der
Schuldenbremse von Verfassung wegen bei
rückläufiger Konjunktur das wissen sie
hoffentlich so und wenn es dann nicht
reicht dann sage ich auch können wir
über die notlagenklausel sprechen woran
uns liegt und das sage ich Ihnen jetzt
ganz deutlich ist dass wir jährlich
präzise abrechnen dass wir die
Verfassung und das Haushaltsrecht
Einhalten von uns werden sie heute keine
pauschalermächtigung kriegens zu 200
Milliarden schlichter Schulden bei denen
wir nicht ansatzweise wissen wofür wann
und wie das Geld ausgegeben werden soll
herzlichen Dank
Matthias Mittelberg ist einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Unionsfraktion und Sie merken meine
Damen und Herren wenn es ums Geld geht
kochen die Emotionen auch schon mal hoch
Matthias Mittelberg hat unter anderem
kritisiert dass die zuständigen Minister
für Wirtschaft aber auch für Finanzen
nicht da sind in dieser Debatte nun die
können sich nicht zwei Teilen die sind
nämlich im Gespräch auf den
regierungschefinnen und Chefs der
Bundesländer in Hannover auch da stehen
wichtige Gespräche an und dass der
Bundeskanzler nicht da ist ist auch
bekannt der ist ja beim Europäischen Rat
in Brüssel Matthias Mörsch der stellt
einer der stellvertretenden Vorsitzende
der SPD-Fraktion ist der nächste Redner
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Kollege Mittelberg man
muss immer überlegen welche Worte wir
man hier wählt wenn sie von Schwachsinn
reden ich wäre sehr vorsichtig an ihrer
Stelle heute diese Begrifflichkeit
tatsächlich zu nehmen wenn Sie
wenn sie verweigern hier heute die
Grundvoraussetzung dass wir die
Bevölkerung und die Unternehmen in
diesem Land schützen können das ist ihr
Handeln heute zu dieser Minute
sie halten ihre Rede daran auf sich zu
beschweren das Minister nicht da sind
ehrlicherweise es ist nicht die Stunde
der Regierung es ist die Stunde des
Parlaments jetzt hier heute die
Grundlagen zu schaffen und das machen
sie nicht
sie werfen der Ampelkoalition vor nicht
zu handeln das was wir hier machen ist
die Ergänzung zu einem 100 Milliarden
Entlastungspaket die wir dreimal schon
vorher in diesem Jahr gemacht haben
jetzt kommt noch ein Paket von 200
Milliarden drauf was Sicherheit in
diesem Land gibt das ist das was wir
hier heute tun liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wenn sie so tun und wenn sie so tun
als wüssten sie nicht worum es geht dann
frage ich mich wirklich wo sie
eigentlich die letzten Wochen und
Monaten gewesen sind es ist im übrigen
es ist im es ist im übrigen es ist im ja
es tut weh ich weiß das war wirklich so
so so eine Vorlage entschuldigung aber
Sie sagen sie hätten irgendwas auf ihrem
Parteitag beschlossen was haben wir denn
hier die ganze Zeit gemacht wir haben
gerungen wie wir die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und wie wir Unternehmen helfen
können und es gibt eine
Expertenkommission die geparkt hat und
diese nun regen sich nicht ganz so auf
seiner hören erstmal zu dann können sie
ja wieder aber es gibt eine
Expertenkommission da war sogar nur ein
Sozialdemokrat beratendes Mitglied das
war keiner hier aus diesem aus diesem
Parlament sondern wir waren beratend
dabei diese Expertenkommission hat
Vorschläge vorgelegt gestern hat der
Bundeskanzler an dieser Stelle gesagt
dass die Bundesregierung die Eckpunkte
dieses Beschlusses
und insofern sind die 200 Milliarden die
wir jetzt machen die Grundbedingungen
dafür dass wir spätestens im März für
alle Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
eine gaspreisbremse bekommen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das was wir hier machen ist die
Grundbedingung dafür dass wir ab 1.1 die
Industrie in diesem Land schützen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und das was wir jetzt hier machen ist
die Grundbedingung dass wir bereits im
Dezember an die Haushalte gehen und dort
die energiebremsen einziehen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen darum geht es
aber ich sage Ihnen auch und das ist
dann parlamentarisches beraten und der
Kollege Fricke hat darauf hingewiesen es
gibt parlamentsvorbehalte die wir jetzt
einziehen und insofern werden wir nicht
blind auch hier der Regierung ein Haken
gibt sondern wir haben als SPD-Fraktion
durchaus Punkte die wir im
parlamentarischen Verfahren klären
wollen zum Beispiel die Versorger in der
Kommission haben gesagt dass sie erst ab
März organisatorisch in der Lage sind
die Bremsen zu ziehen wir wollen dass
wir uns die Phase Dezember bis Februar
noch mal genau angucken denn wir wissen
das ist die Hochzeit natürlich das
Heizens und insofern werden wir auch
darüber reden ob es zum Beispiel eine
Rückwirkung geben kann einer Bremse ob
es noch eine weitere Abschlagszahlung
geben kann und ob überhaupt
gerechtfertigt ist dass wenn man weiß
dass das Parlament eine Bremse einzieht
in diesem Monaten überhaupt noch
überhöhte Abschlagszahlungen fordern
kann das sind Dinge die wir noch klären
müssen und dafür sind wir auch hier
aufgerufen
und genauso wird es darum gehen ob wir
und das ist das Problem was immer bei
schnellen Lösungen der Kollege Fricke
hat er angesprochen die das
gerechtigkeitsmoment um ob wir eine
Obergrenze auch bei der
gaspreisbremse einziehen können um die
Ungerechtigkeiten zu verhindern die da
sind wenn ich beispielsweise die
berühmte Villa mit dem Pool
gleichermaßen fordere auch das wollen
wir prüfen im weiteren Verfahren die
Versorger sagen Ihnen fehlen Daten dann
müssen wir gucken wie wir sie in
besorgen das ist ein wichtiges
gerechtigkeitsmoment
und schließlich geht es auch darum all
die in den Blick zu nehmen die nebengas
mit Pellets oder mit Öl heizen auch das
ist eine Frage die wir hier adressieren
und die wir im parlamentarischen
Verfahren klären deswegen gibt es
weitere Vorschläge von Fonds von
härtefallfonds etc das ist aber die
Grundbedingung überhaupt um einsteigen
zu können dass wir die finanziellen
Mittel haben dieses tatsächlich zu heben
und insofern vielleicht überlegen sich
normal ich glaube sind 60 Minuten das
was sie hier machen ist
verantwortungsvolle verantwortungslose
Oppositionspolitik und insofern bitte
ich Sie wirklich noch mal diese Dinge
tatsächlich zu hinterfragen es ist die
Grundbedingung dafür dass wir diesem
Land helfen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion
Albrecht Glaser
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
diese Regierung hat das Energiegeschäft
mit Russland eingestellt weil sie das zu
Erreichung außenpolitischer Ziele
förderliche
wenn die Regierung dies tut dann muss
sie einen Plan haben für die daraus
entstehenden Folgen sie muss wissen dass
Deutschland bisher 46 % der Ölimporte
und 55 Prozent der Gasimporte aus
Russland bezieht sie muss wissen dass
weder die dahinterstehende Energiemenge
noch die erforderlichen Logistik hierfür
zeitnah ersetzbar ist
diese Regierung muss auch wissen dass
die Energieträger Mineralien und Gas 60
Prozent der Energie der Endenergie
darstellen die hier im Land verbraucht
wird Strom macht 20 Prozent der
Endenergie aus und die Erneuerbaren 8,8
Prozent aus diesen wenigen jedoch
fundamentalen zusammen ergibt sich dass
die
Energieimporte von Russland knapp ein
Drittel der Energiebasis dieses Landes
ausmachen
die schlagartige Beendigung dieses
energieimports muss also zu einer ebenso
schlagartigen Energiekrise in
Deutschland führen
sie bedeutet exorbitante beisserhöhung
für alle Abnehmer Versorgungsengpässe
und Versorgungsunterbrechung
der Energie die Lebensader für eine
moderne Volkswirtschaft und eine
zivilisierte Gesellschaft ist handelt es
sich bei dem was wir jetzt erleben um
einen Anschlag auf diesen Staat und der
ist ausgeführt worden von dieser
Regierung
eine Regierung die unablässig den
Begriff der Verantwortung im Munde führt
muss sie bei einem solchen
extraordinären regierungsversagen auch
tragen
stattdessen legen Sie uns zum zweiten
Mal in diesem Jahr einen Beschluss zu
durchbrechen der Schuldenbremse vor im
Juni haben Sie zusätzlich 116 Milliarden
verlangt wegen der Pandemie und wegen
des russischen angriffskriegs wie sie
dort schon scheiden heute wollen sie
weitere 200 Milliarden und verweisen
erneut auf den russischen Angriffskrieg
und die Einstellung der Gaslieferungen
und was die Höhe des Kredits an die
darauf das ist ein deutliches Zeichen an
Russland sei das möglich verstehen wer
will dabei steht überhaupt noch nicht
fest wer wann was bekommen soll und
Russland zeigen sie dass wir mächtig
Schulden machen müssen zur
Krisenbewältigung ein außerordentliches
Zeichen der Stärke die Kreditmittel
sollen in einem ungewidmeten
Sondervermögen sofort aufgenommen dort
für 23 und 24 gebunkert und bis
2058 durch unsere Enkel getilgt werden
das ist alles so nicht geht hat in der
Rechnungshof erklärt mit dem sie aber
gar nicht reden deshalb werden wir den
durchbrechungsbeschluss auch ablehnen
sie behandeln die Schuldenbremse genauso
wie die EU-Staaten den stabilitäts-
die vorübergehende Unterstützung von
Bürgern und Unternehmen muss sein aber
sie ist keine Lösung des deutschen
Energieproblems und wird schnell
unbezahlbar sie ist nur vertretbar wenn
Sie sofort mit einer neuen
Energiepolitik beginnen auf alle Fälle
einer Energiepolitik bei der die
Kernenergie vorkommt
die empfiehlt übrigens die Kernenergie
auf Kreta wenn Ihnen das weiterhilft
wer Energieversorgung allein auf Wind
und Sonne stützt hat die trivialphysik
nicht verstanden
er produziert damit die nächsten
energiekatastrophen der Rest der Welt
außerhalb Deutschlands weiß dies und
Handel entsprechend wir richten uns in
wir richten uns im Traumland ein und
meinen wir kommen um die nächsten Krisen
drumherum wir kündigen Ihnen an sie
werden stattfinden und sie werden dafür
politisch bezahlen
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen dr Sebastian Schäfer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Putin und seine
Truppen eskalieren ihren terrorkrieg
auch in dieser Woche immer weiter
Drohnenangriffe bedrohen die
Zivilbevölkerung das ist brutal und
niederträchtig
die Energieversorgung in der Ukraine
wird zunehmend zerstört ganz gezielt
jetzt vor dem Winter das ist der
Hintergrund für unsere Debatte heute
Morgen und das dürfen wir bei unserer
doch stark nach innen gerichteten
Debatte nicht vergessen
[Applaus]
die Sorge um die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung um unseren Wohlstand treibt
uns alle um in diesem Hohen Haus naja
fast alle manche wünschen sich ja immer
mehr Krise aber es geht doch darum einen
gemeinsamen Weg zu finden wie wir
unseren Wohlstand erhalten und künftig
auf eine tragfähige nachhaltige
Grundlage stellen können das ist
das ist keine nationale Frage das bleibt
eine europäische Aufgabe und da sehen
wir elementare Fortschritte das ist ja
in der Nacht deutlich geworden
da sind weitere Gespräche notwendig die
Energieminister werden das nächste Woche
in Brüssel weiter konkretisieren
entscheidend bleibt das
putinskalkulation nicht aufgeht und die
EU solidarisch und geschlossen bleibt
und ich will daran erinnern dass wir mit
unserer Fixierung auf russisches
pipeline-gas aus einer miserablen
Situation gestartet sind und bei unseren
europäischen Partnern sehr viel
Vertrauen verloren haben
es ist richtig dass wir jetzt mit dem
Abwehrschirm
so entschlossen den wirtschaftlichen
Folgen des russischen antriebskrieges
begegnen wir setzen mit den 200
Milliarden Euro ein klares Zeichen dass
wir der russischen Aggression trotzen
und zwar so lange wie das notwendig ist
es geht um Sicherheit
Vertrauen und Entlastungen in diesem und
im nächsten Winter für unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für unsere
Unternehmen für unsere sozialen
Einrichtungen und als Haushaltspolitiker
sag ich ihnen wir nutzen alle unsere
Kontrollrechte als Parlamentarierinnen
und Parlamentarier wenn es um solche
Summen geht ist das selbstverständlich
wir werden uns engmaschig über den
Abfluss aus dem WSF informieren lassen
ab 1.1 wird der Haushaltsausschuss
monatlich über die programmausgaben
unterrichtet der Erfolg der Maßnahmen
und Programme wird kontrolliert und
evaluiert wir verhindern Mitnahmeeffekte
es wird keine Boni geben in Unternehmen
die Stützungsmaßnahmen erhalten
wir werden in dieser Krise nur gemeinsam
bestehen und bei allem Verständnis für
ihre Kritik mit ihrem kleinen
politischen Karo kommen wir in dieser
Situation nicht weiter herzlichen Dank
Sebastian Schäfer für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 wie Grünen in dieser Debatte
über den pardon 200 Milliarden Abwehr
Schirm und in dieser Debatte jetzt
gesehene löt stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der Linksfraktion
morgen werden Menschen in sechs
Großstädten auch hier in Berlin unter
dem Motto solidarischer Herbst auf die
Straße gehen aufgerufen haben unter
anderem Gewerkschaften und
Sozialverbände und wir als LINKE
unterstützen diese Demonstration meine
Damen und Herren
und diese Solidarität schießt auch die
Menschen ein die vor dem Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine geflüchtet sind aber
ich sage die Solidarität muss auch für
die Menschen gelten die aus anderen
kriegs-
der Brandanschlag auf die Unterkunft für
geflüchtete Menschen in
Nordwestmecklenburg hat in meiner
Fraktion Trauer und Entsetzen ausgelöst
und darum müssen wir hier im Bundestag
ganz deutlich sagen jeder Politiker und
jede Politikerin ist verpflichtet so zu
sprechen dass daraus keine Stichworte
für solche Verbrechen werden meine Damen
und Herren
meine Damen und Herren eine Frage bleibt
bei dem heutigen Gesetzesentwurf
unbeantwortet wer soll eigentlich die
gigantischen Strom- und Gasrechnungen
bezahlen wir haben eine klare Position
wir sagen die Rechnung müssen die
Krisengewinner bezahlen doch die
Bundesregierung sträubt sich ja mit
Händen und Füßen gegen eine gerechte
Besteuerung von Rüstungsunternehmen und
Stromkonzernen wir brauchen endlich eine
übergewinnsteuer wie sie auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern gibt meine Damen
und Herren
und die große Gefahr besteht doch dass
wir in der Finanzkrise und in der
corona-krise die Kosten wieder auf die
gering und Normalverdiener abgewälzt
werden in Haushaltsberatungen in denen
wir ja gerade stecken sehen wir ja schon
wo der Rotstift angesetzt wurde zum
Beispiel bei den sprachkitas ein für
mich unfassbarer Vorgang meine Damen und
Herren
der Finanzminister steht auf der
Schuldenbremse und lässt soziale
Einrichtungen am ausgestreckten Abend
verhungern wir sagen Ihnen wir brauchen
einen echten Inflationsausgleich für
Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheime der Fuß
muss dauerhaft von der Schuldenbremse
meine Damen und Herren
und nach allen Vorschlägen die uns sehr
nutzerkenntnis gekommen sind allerdings
noch nicht in gesetzeskarakter ist klar
schon ersichtlich dass es wenn es um die
Verteilung der 200 Milliarden Euro geht
Einkommensmillionäre und vermögene
viermal besser bedient werden als
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen und
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen bekommen
ja auch noch weiter den Auftrag zu
sparen ich werde ihr einfach mal fragen
wenn jemand zum Beispiel in einer
kleinen Wohnung mit Fernwärme versorgt
wird und seine Heizung schon auf Null
gestellt hat der kann sie nicht noch auf
-2 herunter regeln das ist technisch
einfach unmöglich das müssten sich mal
überlegen was wir fordern sind echte
anreizende für vermögene Energie zu
sparen glauben Sie wirklich Herr Merz
lässt jetzt sein Privatjet stehen weil
die Energiepreise steigen nein für
Millionäre und Milliardäre wurden keine
Anreize geschaffen um effektiv Energie
zu sparen aber augenscheinlich wollen
sie erreichen Wählerinnen und Wählern
nicht auf die Füße treten der
Bundesrechnungshof das ist schon erwähnt
worden hat das 200 Milliarden
Sondervermögen scharf kritisiert und
hält es für verfassungswidrig
Sondervermögen schießen ja im Augenblick
wie Pilze aus dem Boden und das
Besondere an diesen Vermögen ist ja dass
die Abgeordneten nur kaum beeinflussen
können wie die Bundesregierung mit dem
Geld umgeht sie wollen uns die Katze im
Sack verkaufen und das können wir nicht
akzeptieren meine Damen und Herren
wir
haben ja die Situation dass immer
weniger Menschen Vertrauen in die
Demokratie haben 39 Prozent der
Ostdeutschen zum Beispiel haben das
Vertrauen verloren und darum denke ich
müssen wir besonders alle Verfahren die
wir beschließen in Demokratie gestalten
und Sondervermögen gehören nicht dazu
meine Damen und Herren wir haben
ihnen und Schuldenbremse auch für 2023
auszusetzen dann brauchen wir kein
Sondervermögen dann können wir das
ordentlich aus dem
bundeshaushaltsfinanzieren wir sind für
Vernunft statt Ideologie schließen sich
unserer Meinung an herzlichen Dank
aus der Linksfraktion befürchtet eine
ungerechte Verteilung der Hilfsgelder
und sie vermisst Anreize für Reiche und
Vermögende Energie zu sparen in dieser
Phase der Krise Christoph Meyer ist der
nächste Redner einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
FDP-Fraktion guten Morgen frau
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren Herr Mittelberg sie haben
Ehrlichkeit in der Debatte eingefordert
sie haben sich beschwert darüber dass
Christian Lindner und Herr Habeck nicht
anwesend sind dabei wissen sie doch ganz
genau dass die beiden heute auf
Einladung der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz genau zu
den Themen sprechen wozu auch wir hier
sprechen und sie wissen auch dass wir
versucht haben den Termin nach hinten zu
schieben das ist aber an ihren
unionsministerpräsidenten gescheitert
ist sie sind derjenige der immer
Ehrlichkeit bräuchte sie
und meine Damen und Herren
das gilt auch für den Umgang mit der
Kritik vom Rechnungshof die Kritik daran
dass wir Sondervermögen oder mit
Sondervermögen gegen das Prinzip der
Jährlichkeit im Haushalt verstoßen ist
nicht neu ich frage mich nur warum die
Union in letzten Jahren genau diese
Kritik wenn sie jetzt so relevant ist in
ihren Augen die aufgenommen hat
kommunalinvestitionsförderungsfonds
digitalpakt Schule Ausbau
Ganztagsbetreuung
kinderbetreuungsfinanzierung sie haben
überall die Hand gehoben die Bedenken
haben sie niemals mit vorgetragen beim
Bundeswehr Sondervermögen Anfang dieses
Jahres ebenfalls noch und warum was ist
eigentlich anders ein geheimen Vorbehalt
hatten sie damals ja wohl nicht sie
dokumentieren mit dieser Rede mit ihrer
Positionierung momentan schlicht ein
weiteres Mal dass ich kein Verständnis
von seriöser Oppositionsarbeit haben und
vor allem dass sie in keiner Weise in
keiner Weise bereit sind die mittelbaren
Folgen ihrer gescheiterten sicherheits-
und Energiepolitik der letzten
Jahrzehnte hier mit uns zusammen
aufzuräumen und zu korrigieren
und dann sind wir
beim Sondervermögen des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds im
Jahr haben sie diesen
Vorgang Euro aufgeladen
positionsarbeit in den Zeiten der
corona-krise haben ihnen grün und FDP
vorgemacht wir haben nämlich zugestimmt
und haben uns nicht mit dem billigen
Trick hier mit einem
Entschließungsantrag irgendetwas Worten
hinter den Rechnungshof zu verstecken
ohne eigene Antworten zu haben hier in
die Büsche geschlagen und wir haben die
Garantien
die sie damals so groß aufgeblasen haben
gar nicht benötigt sie mussten das jetzt
korrigieren und deswegen sind die 200
Milliarden die wir jetzt in den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
einstellen an Kredit Ermächtigung nach
unserer Auffassung für die nächsten zwei
Jahre genau richtig dimensioniert und
wenn sie jetzt mehrfach sagen dass sie
nicht wissen wofür das Geld ist der
Zweck ist doch eng der Zweck ist doch
eng umrissen wir reden über die Gas und
die strompreisbremse wir reden über
unternehmenshilfen und wir reden über
die Refinanzierung der KfW das können
Sie alles nachlesen wenn sie denn die
entsprechenden Unterlagen gelesen hätten
und wir senden mit diesem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds und mit
dem Abwehrschirm ein Signal der
Entschlossenheit es wurde eben schon
angesprochen für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger für die Unternehmen dass sie sich
auf die Unterstützung des Staates in
dieser Krise verlassen können und das
einzige was ich in dieser Woche geändert
hat ist das die Union wir haben es eben
bei Herr Mittelmeer gehört nicht mehr zu
Schuldenbremse steht
und das ist ja das was ich schon
angekündigt hat in den letzten Monaten
es gab immer ein paar Haushaltspolitiker
noch Schuldenbremse gerufen haben die
Fachpolitiker bei ihnen haben bereits
Ausgaben mehr Aufwüchse in den letzten
Haushaltsberatungen und auch jetzt
entsprechend gestellt sie können sich
darauf verlassen dass die Ampel auch im
nächsten Jahr weiter an dem Prinzipien
der Generationengerechtigkeit festhalten
wird dass wir die Schuldenbremse
einhalten werden und dass wir die Kritik
die sie hier äußern mit Lügen strafen
werden dann werden wir nächstes Jahr neu
diskutieren vielleicht entschuldigen
sich dann vielleicht kommen sie dann
auch zur seriösen Oppositionspolitik
zurück ich danke Ihnen
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Christian Haase
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es herrscht
Verunsicherung in unserem Land in
Familien sind die Thema der
Energiekosten täglich auf dem Tisch bei
jedem Meeting in jedem Unternehmen und
wahrscheinlich bekommen auch sie täglich
Anrufe von besorgten Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern und Unternehmen da ist der
Bäcker aus meinem Wahlkreis der von
einer Verzehnfachung der Gaspreise
berichtet es kommen viele Leute von
weither sein Brot zu kaufen aber eine
Verdoppelung der Brotpreise will er
seinen Kunden nicht zumuten bereits in
der corona-krise hat er ein Teil seiner
Alterssicherung eingesetzt das will er
nicht noch mal tun wenn die Regierung
nicht jetzt handelt schließt er seinen
Betrieb
da ist die Witwe der Vermieter teilt mit
der heizkostenabschlag wird sich
verdreifachen sie weiß nicht wie sie das
von ihrer Witwenrente bezahlen soll sie
spart schon wo sie kann der Garten ist
längst schon zum Ersatz des Supermarktes
geworden da ist der Inhaber eines
Modehauses die Verkaufsräume lernen sich
deutlich spürbar selbst ein
verkaufsoffener Sonntag
kommt nicht zum erhofften konsumschub
und am Sonntag so Montag bringen die
Leute die Mäntel wieder zurück weil sie
sich einfach nicht mehr leisten können
selbst der harbeck-kulli wird zum
Ladenhüter und dabei ist die
corona-krise noch gar nicht überwunden
meine Damen und Herren und deshalb ist
es richtig und wichtig jetzt über
strompreisbremsen zu sprechen jetzt über
gaspreisbremsen zu sprechen und nicht
nur die Finanzierung zu machen sondern
endlich zu sagen wie wir den Menschen
und Unternehmen in diesem Land helfen
wollen
und wenn Sie Ihren Abwehrschirm hier so
loben dann sage ich Ihnen dieser Schirm
hat keinen Stock mit ihrem Schirm stehen
die Leute weiterhin im Regen weil sie
den zweiten Teil einfach nicht angehen
wollen es war doch allen klar nach dem
Einfall von Einfall von Putin wird es zu
einer Energiekrise kommen das war allen
klar der Kanzler hat gesagt er wusste
das schon im Herbst aber außer dass er
Nord Stream 2 durchgewunken hat hat er
nicht drauf reagiert er hätte ja was tun
können schon an der Stelle hat er nicht
gemacht was hätte also eine Regierung
getan auf den energieknebel von Putin
Angebotsausweitung wäre es gewesen
biogasdeckel Weg Kohlekraftwerke aus der
Reserve Kernkraftwerke die Laufzeit
verlängern LNG als Ersatz all das hat
die Regierung getan aber zu langsam zu
spät und immer nur halbherzig meine
Damen und Herren das wäre direkt am
Anfang des Krieges notwendig gewesen das
wäre ein Wumms für den Energiemarkt
gewesen dann keine Zirkulation und
diesen doppelwumms vom heute gegeben
und zuletzt konnten wir das ja an dem
inszenierten Schauspiel zur
kernkraftverlängerung sehen da wird
gesagt ja wir haben jetzt endlich was
getan bis zum
15.4.2023 wird die Laufzeit verlängert
heute kriegen wir einen Beschluss
vorgelegt da steht drin die Krise dort
bis Juni 2024 das passt auch nicht
zusammen wenn Sie nicht bereit sind die
Dinge auch mal zu Ende zu denken
wer glaubt dass heute irgendwas
konkretes beschlossen wird er irrt wir
sollen hier ein Geldsack mit Schulden
füllen ohne zu wissen was mit dem Geld
passiert die gaskommission hat geliefert
ihre Regierung Frau Hasselmann liefert
nicht die strompreisbremse so hört man
soll erst im November finalisiert werden
ihre entscheidungsverweigerung
frustriert die Familien und Unternehmen
in diesem Land wenn er mir jetzt sagt
wir gucken uns das erstmal im Januar
Februar an und werden im Frühjahr dann
irgendwann entscheiden ja nenne ich das
soziale Kälte Herr mir ist das ist
soziale Kälte und kein Respekt vor den
Menschen in diesem Land
und es wird Insolvenzen geben es wird
Insolvenzen geben das hängt jetzt schon
anders können Sie jetzt schon an den
Zahlen lesen und jeder dieser Betriebe
gilt auf ihre Kappe lieber Ampel
und wenn Sie das Gesetz hier allein als
Signal an die Märkte verstehen dann sage
ich ihnen wir arbeiten hier nicht für
Märkte wir arbeiten für die Menschen und
Unternehmen in diesem Land das ist
wichtig
wir brauchen die Entscheidung über die
Bremsen jetzt und wenn sie ihre Redezeit
hier dafür verwenden drei Viertel ihrer
Redezeit verwenden Sie damit uns als
cdu/csu zu beschimpfen als ihre Konzepte
endlich offenzulegen und den Menschen in
diesem Land zu helfen wir kommen gerne
in den nächsten zwei Wochen zu einer
Sondersitzung zusammen wenn sie endlich
liefern kommen wir in den nächsten zwei
Wochen hier zusammen und entscheiden wie
es bei der gaspreisbremse und
strompreisbremse weitergeht wir sagen ja
zu niedrigen Energiepreisen wir sagen
nein zu in der zu ihrer Finanzierung
schalten Sie Ihre Ampel mal auf Grün
danke schön Christian Haase ist
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion die hier auch ein
Entschließungsantrag eingereicht hat in
die heutige Sitzung und darin fordert
sie unter anderem die Laufzeit der im
Betrieb befindlichen Atomkraftwerke
mindestens bis zum 31 Dezember 24
weiterlaufen zu lassen
Kohlekraftwerke zu nutzen der
beschleunigten Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien und die volle Auslastung der
LNG Terminals WPS da aus der
SPD-Fraktion
aber es wäre folgerichtig wenn die Union
dann mal eine Oppositionspolitik
betreiben würde die diese Verunsicherung
nicht hochjagst sondern die konstruktiv
Vorschläge einbringen damit wir um die
besten Lösungen bringen können
und Herren wir setzen heute hier den
Rahmen den Rahmen dafür dass wir Gas und
wärmepreisbremse für diejenigen
einführen können die am meisten darunter
leiden und zwar mit Planungssicherheit
mit Planungssicherheit weil wir schon
jetzt Mittel bereitstellen können mit
denen wir Abschlagszahlungen im Dezember
finanzieren und aber auch jetzt schon
die Hilfen für den Winter 23 24 planen
können wir setzen den Rahmen für einen
härtefallfonds der dann auch noch
denjenigen helfen kann die noch weitere
Hilfen benötigen benötigen und zwar
Unternehmen aber auch
Forschungseinrichtungen
Bildungseinrichtungen von Kitas bis zur
Hochschule Krankenhäuser alle
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher wir
machen den Rahmen weit in diesem Gesetz
und wir setzen den Rahmen dafür meine
Damen und Herren dass wir mit der
energiepreisbremse auch endlich in den
Markt eingreifen weil das notwendig ist
und damit meine Damen und Herren ist
klar dass wir in dieser Krise auch
weiter so unterwegs sind das gilt you
never walk alone
und vielleicht hilft es der
cdu/csu-fraktion Herr Mittelberg ich
würde mich freuen wenn Sie mir auch
zuhören würden weil sie nämlich wenn sie
von einem Blankoscheck und davon einer
Blanco Herr Heidelberg wenn Sie von
einer Blanco Vorlage sprechen die hier
ausgeteilt wird dann haben sie glaube
ich die Änderungsanträge die vorliegen
entweder nicht gelesen oder es ist ihr
Ziel bewusst die Menschen in die Irre zu
führen denn das was wir heute
beschließen werden sind
200 die wir bereitstellen in einem
sonderformance wir sperren die aber
sofort wieder wir sperren hier weil
heute die Stunde des Parlament ist
Matthias mirtsch hat es gesagt wir
werden erst dann auszahlen wenn die
Bundesregierung uns die konkreten
Gesetzesentwürfe und Vorlagen habt und
dann gilt es darüber aber abzustimmen
Herr Mittelberg ich finde es immer noch
schön wenn Sie mir zuhören würden denn
sie können noch was lernen dass wir erst
dann auszahlen dass wir erst dann
auszahl wenn die konkreten Maßnahmen
vorlegen wir stärken das Parlament mit
berichtspflichtungen nicht nur an den
Haushaltsausschuss und wir werden auch
als SPD-Fraktion das kann ich versichern
sehr stark abwägen dass wir genauso ab
auszahlen dass es auch sozial ausgewogen
sein wird am Ende
und ganz wichtig
und möglich über die Zustimmung der CDU
freuen wir werden sicherstellen dass bei
all denjenigen die als Unternehmen von
Hilfen des Staates profitieren werden
keine Dividenden und keine Boni
ausgezahlt werden sondern wer durch
Steuergelder profitiert muss an der
Stelle darauf verzichten das ist sozial
gerecht
schauen sich mal die Änderungsanträge an
die wir im Übrigen gestern auch im
vorgestern im Haushaltsausschuss hatten
meine Damen und Herren wir haben die
Kraft
diesem Erpressungsversuch Putins Stand
zu halten wir werden mit diesen 200
Milliarden die sozialen Härten abfedern
wir werden unseren Wirtschaftsstandort
sichern das tun wir als Staat mit
staatlichen Eingriffen und darum zeigt
sich meines Erachtens heute einmal mehr
dass insbesondere in der Krise je mehr
vom der Markt wird es schon Regeln nicht
gilt und darum muss eine der lessons
learnt neben dem akuten Krisenmanagement
dass wir jetzt betreiben auch sein dass
wir klar haben wir brauchen resilientere
Lieferketten die wir aufbauen müssen wir
brauchen mehr eigene
Produktionskapazitäten hier in
Deutschland zum Beispiel bei der
Medikamentenversorgung um nicht wieder
in eine Abhängigkeit anderer Länder zu
können und wir brauchen den massiven
Aufbau erneuerbaren Energien um zu mehr
Energie Souveränität zu kommen
und darum brauchen wir meine Damen und
Herren ein umfassenderes Verständnis von
Daseinsvorsorge Daseinsvorsorge die nie
wieder so abhängig davon sein kann von
internationalen Marktmechanismen und von
einzelnen und darum zeigt sich auch die
umfassende Daseinsvorsorge die wir
brauchen die gehört in die öffentliche
Hand herzlichen Dank
Wiebke ist da aus der SPD-Fraktion der
Bundestag diskutiert über die Befüllung
des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds bzw
dessen Neuausrichtung und neu
Aktivierung es geht um die 200
Milliarden Euro die dann aus diesem Topf
fließen sollen um und zu unterstützen
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber auch
Unternehmen die von hohen Gas und
Strompreisen betroffen sind Peter
Böhringer haushaltspolitischer Sprecher
der afd-fraktion ist ampult niemals
gerecht umsetzbaren Gaspreis der
gelungen ausgestaltet werden sollen wer
bekommt Geld welche Preise werden wohl
gedeckelt wie soll das operativ
umgesetzt werden das alles wird erst in
Monaten per Verordnung geregelt das
vorliegende Gesetz ist schlicht nicht
entscheidungsreif
testfrage testfrage an sie alle ob sie
den lächerlich kürzen im Gesetz
enthaltenen Wirtschaftsplan des 200
Milliarden Fonds auch gelesen haben wie
viel Geld sieht er für die angekündigten
dezemberzahlungen vor und ich sag's
Ihnen hier drin stehen genau 0 Euro
gaspreisbremse Null strompreisbremse 0
weitere Stützungen 0 also Frau ist da
man kann nicht sperren was im
Wirtschaftsplan gar nicht drin steht es
geht einfach nicht da ist nichts zu
sperren wir haben es nicht jedenfalls
nichts für 22
und doch soll der Bundestag nun heute
zustimmen dass 200 Milliarden Euro neue
Schulden in die Rücklage eines
zweckentfremdeten sonst vollkommen
undefinierten schattenhaushaltsgepackt
werden es wäre absurd der Regierung
einen solchen Blankoscheck auszureichen
der einzig richtige Weg für dieses
Gesetz wäre ein Nachtragshaushalt 22
über die nur recht kleine Summe die für
die geplante dezember energiezahlung an
Menschen und Unternehmen tatsächlich
ausgezahlt wird der Finanzminister nicht
anwesend will jedoch mehr als das
20-fache in den 22er Haushalt einstellen
was seine zwölf Monatsbilanz dann auf
glatte 500 Milliarden Euro bringt auch
der Bundesrechnungshof hat genau wie
schon seit Jahren die AFD und
festgestellt der buchungsdruck der
Reservebildung ist hochwahrscheinlich
verfassungswidrig wir sagen er ist
verfassungswidrig
die 200 Milliarden Euro werden 2022
nicht benötigt der einstellen heute in
den WSF dient einzig der Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse die derzeit
glücklicherweise noch ausgesetzt ist
warum geht das überhaupt und hier ist
auch die Union unehrlich an dieser
Stelle weil noch die unionsgeführte
groko 2021 einen weiteren Trick erfunden
hat wonach Kredite schon und nur im Jahr
der Kredit Ermächtigung auf die
Schuldenbremse angerechnet werden die
praktischerweise in corona-zeiten damals
ausgesetzt war und heute immer noch ist
zum Glück liegen diese Tricks nun
endlich in Karlsruhe kehren Sie zum
recht zurück das gilt für alle
unser heute abzustimmender Antrag gibt
Ihnen die Chance auf eine saubere
etatisierung der erforderlichen Gelder
stimmen sie einfach zu dann kann den
Menschen und Unternehmen geholfen werden
die unter der aktuellen falschpolitik
leiden für eine nur symptomatische
Linderung der dümmsten Energiepolitik
der Welt mit Steuergeld sind die
Schadensummen aber viel zu hoch nötig
ist das ursächliche abwenden des
existenziell gefährlichen
energienotstands wir sagen das seit
Monaten und schon vor dem ukraine-krieg
haben wir das gesagt hören Sie endlich
auch beim Energiethema auf die rationale
Stimme der AFD herzlichen Dank
Peter Böhringer ist haushaltspolitischer
Sprecher der
afd-fraktion der Bundestag ich habe
vorhin schon mal gesagt nicht nur über
den Gesetzentwurf
zur Änderung des
stabilisierungsfondsgesetz auch auch das
Thema Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz wird
hier noch mal abgestimmt Felix Mannheim
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
gegründet 90 die Grünen in Opposition
zur unionsgeführten Bundesregierung
standen hat diese Fraktion an jeder
Stelle in den zentralen Fragen der
Bewältigung großer Krisen die Regierung
gestützt das war bei der Finanzkrise so
das war bei der Griechenland Rettung so
und das war bei der Pandemie so warum
haben sie diese Größe nicht warum
haben sie diese Größe nicht Herr März
warum suchen Sie zwanghaft nach
irgendeiner Möglichkeit
abzulehnen was diese Regierung zur
Abfederung der Energiekrise für die
Gesellschaft für die Wirtschaft jetzt
vorhat sie haben monatelang monatelang
sind sie durchs Land gezogen und haben
gesagt bloß keine Gaspreis gasumlage
kein Wort zu Finanzierung jetzt gibt es
keine gasumlage jetzt gibt es eine
gaspreisbremse und eine strompreisbremse
mit einer soliden haushaltsrechtlich
vollkommen akzeptablen Finanzierung und
sie geben hier zu Protokoll und ich
hoffe dass das einfach viele viele
Menschen sehen sie geben hier zu
Protokoll die Unionsfraktion und Herr
Merz wollen nicht dass es jetzt
Planbarkeit für die Unternehmen und für
die Gesellschaft gibt dass sie über
diesen und über den nächsten Winter
kommen
und man muss ja schon man muss ja schon
fragen wie sie das eigentlich mit sich
selbst vereinbaren können sich hier zu
beschweren diese Regierung hätte so viel
Zeit ins Land gehen zu lassen und es
gibt keine Planbarkeit die sollen die
Unternehmen denn jetzt wissen wie es
weitergehen soll und hier wollen Sie
verhindern dass wir bis zum Juni 2024
die finanzielle Grundlage dafür schaffen
dass diese Entlastung stattfindet das
ist doch nicht mit dialektisch das ist
doch schon zufrieden
und Herr Middelberg
mich wundert ja nicht dass sie die
Anträge und die Gesetzesvorlagen der
Regierung nicht lesen oder zumindest
nicht ausreichend lesen aber sehr
anscheinend ihren eigenen
Entschließungsantrag nicht gelesen wenn
sie behaupten das gar nicht klar ist
wofür das Geld ausgegeben werden soll
meine Damen und Herren mit diesem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds machen
wir eigentlich viel mehr als im Namen
steckt das heißt
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds aber
eigentlich ist es ein Fonds zur
Stabilisierung der Gesellschaft der
freien und der demokratischen der
resilienten und widerstandsfähigen
Gesellschaft gegen Wladimir Putin und
gegen seine hilfershelfer hier in
Deutschland das ist das was hier zu
gewartet steht
die gaspreiskommission hat vor nicht
allzu langer Zeit einen guten Vorschlag
vorgelegt der jetzt in der Regierung und
im Parlament diskutiert wird um
umzusetzen was jetzt notwendig ist mit
der gaspreisbremse dafür zu sorgen dass
sie Spitzen abgefedert werden mit der
strompreisbremse dafür zu sorgen dass
auch an den strompreisende reale
Entlassung passiert natürlich zum einen
das Schreiben sie auch ihr
mitlassungsantrag
Entschließungsantrag zum einen natürlich
darüber dass übergewinne abgeschöpft und
der Allgemeinheit zurückgeführt werden
aber Sie müssen doch mal anerkennen dass
es Härtefälle gibt die darüber nicht
abgedeckt werden können das betrifft
einzelne Unternehmen das betrifft aber
auch soziale Einrichtungen das betrifft
die Krankenhäusern viele viele mehr mit
denen wir uns doch auch beschäftigen
müssen und deswegen werden wir uns auch
von ihrer
obstruktionspolitik nicht beirren lassen
Herr merkt sie haben gerade bei den 16
Jahren direkt aufgescheucht
sie beschweren sich hier immer dass wir
Ihnen 16 Jahre schlechte
Regierungspolitik vorhalten ich muss
sagen die letzten 16 Monate
Oppositionspolitik für ihn nicht besser
das hat mich nicht mehr überzeugt
sie sagen immer nur was nicht geht sagen
immer nur was nicht geht warum man
irgendetwas nicht tun dürfte ich finde
es gut dass sie das so deutlich den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern transparent
machen ein letztes meine Damen und
Herren mit dem was wir jetzt tun ist
natürlich die Arbeit noch nicht getan
all das muss jetzt noch in Gesetze
gegossen werden und wir müssen darüber
hinaus eine dritte Aufgabe eine dritte
Aufgabe sehr ernst nehmen wir
stabilisieren die Wirtschaft gegen die
Rezession wir stabilisieren die
Gesellschaft gegen diese Angriffe und
jetzt müssen wir auch noch unsere
Energieversorgung noch weiter
stabilisieren mit mehr Effizienz mit
mehr Einsparung und damit werden wir in
den nächsten Monaten noch einige Zeit
verbringen vielleicht wenn sie dann ein
bisschen konstruktiver noch vielen Dank
Felix bannaschak Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen in der Debatte über den 200
Milliarden Euro Rettungsschirm eine
muntere Debatte wenn man es positiv
formuliert in
Teilen allerdings und das ganze
fraktionsübergreifend gelegentlich auch
recht polemisch Dennis Rohde ist ampult
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion
der Debatte bis hierher gefolgt ist muss
man glaube ich am 1 am Anfang noch mal
feststellen wir haben dieses Paket nicht
gewollt es war nicht Bestandteil der
Koalitionsverhandlungen wir haben
darüber nicht zu der Zeitpunkt der
Bildung dieser Koalition diskutiert dass
wir heute über 200 Milliarden Euro
diskutieren hat sich niemand ausgesucht
das ist allein Ergebnis des
Angriffskrieges von Vladimir Putin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die reagieren
und wir reagieren auf unterschiedlichste
Art und Weise und die eine ist dass wir
in einem wirklichen Rekordtempo die
Infrastruktur für erneuerbare Energien
für LNG für später nachhaltigen
wasserstoffausbau noch nie wurden
Infrastrukturprojekte in Deutschland so
schnell vorangebracht und das ist etwas
was wir immer wieder betonen sollten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber zur Wahrheit gehört neue Märkte
erschließen neue Kapazitäten ausbauen
das wird nicht von heute auf morgen
gehen das wird trotzdem Zeit brauchen
auch wenn wir optimistisch sind dass die
ersten lng-schiffe dieses Jahr noch
anlanden aber wir wollen diese Zeit die
wir brauchen um Angebot und Nachteile
wieder in den Einklang zu bringen nicht
wir wollen nicht in dieser Zeit die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger alleine lassen
sondern wir wollen sie spürbar entlasten
wir wollen dass Sie durch die nächsten
Winter kommen liebe Kollegen und deshalb
diskutieren wir heute über 200
Milliarden und
das dann die Union vom
parteitagsbeschlüssen spricht und das
ist doch konkrete Vorschläge gebe ich
wäre als europäischer konservativer in
diesen Tagen sehr vorsichtig mit
Schnellschüssen das kann kräftig nach
hinten losgehen ich finde wir brauchen
nicht den erstbesten sondern den besten
Vorschlag liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und genau deswegen genau deswegen ist es
doch richtig dass das passiert was
Matthias Mirsch gesagt hat nämlich dass
man diejenigen die wirklich Erfahrung in
den Bereichen hat in einer
Expertenkommission dazu zusammengeholt
hat das Politik dabei ist aber dass
diejenigen diskutieren wie schaffen wir
es Entlastung in diesem Land
sicherzustellen aber eben weil da auch
Expertinnen und Experten diskutieren
Politik zwar dabei ist aber am Ende dann
in die Umsetzung erst kommt ist es doch
auch richtig dass dieses Parlament heute
quasi als sein Hoheitsrecht sagt was das
Ganze kosten soll und kosten darf das
was wir heute beschließen nämlich den
Rahmen von 200 Milliarden festzulegen
das ist gelebtes Königsrecht das
Haushaltsrecht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und jetzt ist damit eben der Gegenteil
das Gegenteil eines Blankoschecks und
ich will es noch deutlicher machen wir
beschließen heute die Summe und ja die
konkreten Maßnahmen werden erst in den
nächsten Wochen auf uns zukommen aber
wir stellen sicher dass mit jeder
Maßnahme ganz egal über den gesetzlichen
oder den Verordnungsweg jede Maßnahme
die Geld kostet muss wieder durch den
Deutschen Bundestag wir behalten das
Heft des Handelns in der Hand und ich
finde das ist auch wichtig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ich habe in der Debatte ja gerade
immer wieder diesen Vorwurf gehört das
sei alles so intransparent da werden
Säcke gefüllt und in Keller gebracht das
ist wirklich sehr intransparent ist es
so intransparent dass jeder hier im Haus
mitbekommen hat es geht um 200
Milliarden Euro liebe Kolleginnen das
ist das erste das zweite es ist so in
transparent dass der Wirtschaftsplan die
konkrete Verausgabung am Ende auch
wieder im Haushaltsausschuss diskutiert
und beschlossen werden muss es ist so
intransparent dass jeder Bürger sehen
kann nachher im Wirtschaftsplan wie viel
ist denn von den 200 Milliarden
abgeflossen wie viel ist noch drin wofür
wurde es ausgegeben ich finde das was
wir hier machen ist das Gegenteil von
Intransparenz wir verstecken ist nicht
in einigen Einzelplänen hier mal eine
Maßnahme da mal eine Maßnahme sondern
wir bündeln und stellen gebündelt da das
ist maximale Transparenz und es ist das
Gegenteil von Intransparenz liebe
Kolleginnen
und es geht ja auch gar nicht bei dem
Vorwurf um die Sache ich stelle mir mal
vor wir hätten das gemacht was Christian
Hase hier gefordert hätte wir würden das
in die nächsten Haushaltsverhandlungen
mit einbringen wir würden gucken was wir
konkret dann etatisieren wenn wir das
machen würden dann würden sie uns davor
schreiben würden und sie uns doch
vorwerfen wir würden für keine
Planungssicherheit sorgen wir würden nur
Monat für Monat gucken und wir werden
uns der größte dieser Krise nicht
bewusst ihm geht es doch nicht um Kritik
ihm geht es plumps dagegen sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und das ist der Unterschied und Felix
banatak hat das gerade gesagt und ich
will das weil wir immer in diesen
Konstellation mit in
Regierungsverantwortung hier auch noch
mal sagen das ist der Unterschied
unserer heutigen Koalitionspartner zu
unserem vorherigen Koalitionspartner als
der WSF eingeführt wurde war auch noch
nicht klar wie teuer das ganze wird war
auch noch nicht klar für was genau am
Ende verausgabt wird als der WSF
eingeführt wurde haben wir über 600
Milliarden Euro diskutiert und grün und
FDP haben aufgrund ihrer
staatspolitischen Verantwortung
zugestimmt und haben nicht dieses
Kasperletheater aufgeführt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich komme zum Schluss frau Präsidentin
der Rahmen den wir heute setzen erst
richtig und er ist angemessen wir als
Deutscher Bundestag behalten das Heft
des Handels in der Hand von daher glaube
ich kann jeder Parlamentarier heute mit
guten Gewissen zustimmen vielen Dank
Dennis Rohde haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion nennt das
Auftreten der Unionsfraktion in dieser
Debatte ein Kasperletheater und er hat
zwischenzeitlich wiederholt WSF gesagt
das wissen sie natürlich was er damit
meint nämlich den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds von ich
sag's zur Sicherheit einfach noch mal
dazu Florian osner aus der CSU
Landesgruppe Istan
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wäre die Bundesregierung eine
Privatperson so hätte er inzwischen jede
vernünftige Bank das Konto gesperrt oder
alle Kreditkarten eingezogen kaum ist
das Limit erschöpft wird die nächste
Karte ausgereizt die Finanzpolitik der
Ampel entpuppt sich immer mehr zu einem
gefährlichen Schneeballsystem und für
jedes neue Problem wird ein neuer
Sondervermögen ein deklarierter
schuldentopf aufgemacht und mit Verlaub
bemerkt an meine Vorredner Herrmann
Größe zu tun eigentlich nichts mit Größe
zu tun wenn man hier Blankoschecks und
schuldentöpfe aufmacht und von Denis
Rohde habe ich gelernt das ist zum
Königsrecht gehört Schulden zu machen
und Blankoschecks auszustellen also dies
ist nicht die dies die Problemlösung
aller Ampel jedoch nicht die
Problemlösung wie wir sie als CDU und C
so vertreten
wir wir kämpfen wir kämpfen also Union
nur die Ruhe nur die Ruhe im Gegensatz
zu ihnen komme ich noch zu den Inhalten
was man machen kann wir kämpfen also
Union für eine Entlastung der Bürger und
Unternehmer jedoch ist es für uns nicht
nachvollziehbar und allem die Ampel
Vorräte haben das bestätigt nach welcher
Berechnung diese 200 Milliarden sich
zusammensetzen auch bleibt völlig offen
wie neben der Gas nun die
strompreisbremse schlussendlich
gestaltet ist und wie Öl und Pellets die
komplett vergessen wurden wie hier
geholfen wird der komplette ländliche
Raum wird meiner Ansicht nach
vergessener die Ampel hat zuerst ein
Preisschild erstellt ohne zu wissen wie
das fertige Produkt am Ende aussehen
soll als Union hätten wir eine
vernünftige Reihenfolge gewählt erst die
konkreten Maßnahmen benannt dann erklärt
wie das zu finanzieren ist das wäre die
richtige Vorgehensweise und keine
Artikel blankoschek
jetzt jetzt lieber werden wir konkret
mit unserem Entschließungsantrag bieten
wir konkrete konkrete Lösungsvorschläge
an wie man den hohen Energiepreisen
begegnen kann erstens es gehören
wirklich alle Optionen alle Optionen der
Energieerzeugung in unserem Land auf den
Tisch nur wenn wir es packen die
Energieknappheit in den Griff zu
bekommen werden die Energiepreise auch
wieder sinken deshalb müssen wir alle
drei noch im Betrieb befindlichen
Kernkraftwerke begrenzt bis 2024
weiterlaufen lassen damit würden alle
Stromkunden durch niedrige Preise
entlastet das sogenannte Machtwort von
Scholz ist deshalb schier
unverantwortlich hier gehen rot-grüne
Partei Ideologien vor die Interessen
unseres Landes
Deutschland
Deutschland hat heute bereits ein asiven
Wettbewerbsnachteil aufgrund der
höchsten aufgrund der höchsten
Strompreise weltweit jetzt in dieser
energiemangelage bin ich nur weniger
Monate zusätzlich Produzenten aus dem
Markt zu nehmen macht uns noch
abhängiger und treibt die Preisspirale
zusätzlich nach oben wir müssen deshalb
alles daran legen unsere Spitzenposition
bei grundlastfähigen erneuerbaren
Energien weiter auszubauen schon heute
ist beispielsweise der Anteil in Bayern
Liebe grüne in Bayern mit 52 Prozent aus
Wind Wasser Sonne und Biomasse fast
doppelt so hoch wie im
Bundesdurchschnitt das ist aber wahre
Erfolgsgeschichte
zweitens
zweitens wir müssen verzichtbare
Projekte einspannen Blick in den
Haushalt 2023 zeigt ist gebe
Einsparmöglichkeiten zu haben Beispiele
der bundfinanziert weit den Projekte die
eigentlich Länder Angelegenheit sind wie
Nachfolge 9 Euro Tickets das Kanzleramt
wird für die enorme Summe von
777 Millionen Euro erweitert und das
Bürgergeld wird eingeführt mit sage und
schreibe Mehrkosten von 4,8 Milliarden
Euro die Arbeit verteuert und nichts zu
noch attraktiver macht obwohl jede
helfende Hand in unserem Land gebraucht
wird das braucht in dieser Krisenzeit
wirklich keiner also weg damit
Liebe Ampel verzichten Sie auf alle die
ihn lieb gewordenen und jetzt wieder
bestätigten haushaltsticks mit unserer
Kritik stehen wir übrigens nicht allein
da sondern haben hier den
Bundesrechnungshof fest an unserer Seite
der kommt in seinem Bericht zu einem
vernichteten fazit Die etatisierung der
Mitte in den Sondervermögen verstärkt
die bereits bestehende Intransparenz des
Bundeshaushalts ich möchte zu einem
Beispiel festmachen würden wir alle
Ausgaben im Sondervermögen im nächsten
Jahr mit dem regulären Kernhaushalt 2023
summieren wären wir nicht bei den
veranschlagten 445 Milliarden Euro
sondern bei sage und schreibe
613 Milliarden Euro also 38% höher als
ausgewiesen das hat wirklich überhaupt
nichts mit Transparenz zu tun
der vorgesehene und am Ende wird
entscheidend sein die Kreditaufnahme
hervorrat verstehst auch gegen den
verfassungsgemäßen Grundsatz der
Jährlichkeit wir hatten es heute schon
mehrfach angesprochen der vorgesehene
notlagenbeschluss frau Präsidentin des
Deutschen Bundestages braucht den
Artikel 115 zwei Grundgesetz zwingend
den erforderlichen zeitlichen
Veranlassungszusammenhang das heißt die
Mittel dürfen nur in unmittelbaren
Zusammenhang der Energiekrise stehen und
für nichts anderes verwendet werden wir
lassen uns da überraschen Liebe Ampel
mit so einer Finanz- und
Haushaltspolitik ist wahrhaft kein Staat
zu machen ich rate Ihnen stimmen Sie
unsere Entschließungsantrag zu und
sorgen Sie gemeinsam für und mit uns für
eine ehrliche Entlastung bei den
Energiepreisen ohne Rekordschulden und
ohne Schattenhaushalten herzlichst
Vergelt's Gott fürs zu hören
Florian usner unüberhörbar CSU
Landesgruppe ich meine jetzt nur die
Aussprache Michael Kellner ist wenn ich
so Redner Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär beim
Bundeswirtschaftsminister
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren wir entscheiden heute
als Parlament ob wir mit den 200
Milliarden Euro schweren Abwehrschirm
die Substanz und die zukunftskraft
unserer Volkswirtschaft absichern wir
entscheiden uns mit dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds auch
darüber dass wir nicht nur einzeln
Branchen helfen sondern allen
Unternehmen wir zeigen ja
Handlungsfähigkeit in den Zeiten der
Krise und wenn ich hier die Debatte
zusammenfasse und höre was die Union
vorschlägt dann muss ich sagen sie
stehen auf verhaltensstache die Ampel
handelt die Union hampelt
mit dem
wirtschaftsorganisierungsfonds
finanzieren wir die Strom- und
gaspreisbremse und orientieren uns dabei
an dem Vorschlag der
expertinnenkommission Gas und Wärme das
machen wir übrigens auch bei der
strompreisbremse mit der gaspreisbremse
entlasten wir alle Unternehmen und
privaten Haushalte und schaffen damit
Planungssicherheit ich finde den
Vorschlag der gaskommission richtig in
einem ersten Schritt zu entlasten indem
wir über die Versorger gehen das hilft
schnell wir schlagen damit eine
finanzielle Brücke bis zur regulären
Einführung der gaspreisbremse im
kommenden Jahr die Kommission die
gaspreiskommission schlägt in einer
zweiten Stufe vor die Preise für
industrielle Verbraucher bei 7 Cent ohne
Abgaben für Gas zu deckeln für andere
Unternehmen und privaten Haushalte
schlägt sie ein Bruttopreis von 12 Cent
vor das klingt teurer kommt aber auf
dasselbe hinaus für die Unternehmen für
die Industrieunternehmen und für die
Gewerbe- und privaten Haushalte es
werden damit Grund in Gänze für größere
Teil übernommen aber es wird nicht alles
übernommen wir brauchen Preise als
steuerungs- und spar-
starteten wir bereits mit einer
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm für
Energie und handelsintensive Unternehmen
mit dem jetzigen Abwehrschirm von 200
Milliarden Euro können wir diese
Engführung überwinden und alle
Unternehmen unterstützen mit dem
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm und das
ursprünglich geplante kamo-programm
gehen in diese Maßnahmen auf denn es
geht nicht darum weiter zu diskutieren
welche Branchen besonders unterstützt
werden müssen und welche nicht sondern
maßgeblich darum allen Unternehmen zu
helfen und zwar so schnell und so
unbürokratisch wie möglich auch das
haben wir aus den corona-hilfen gelernt
wir wollen nachdem wir heute den WSS
beschließen im November den Bundestag
erreichen so dass wir unter Hochdruck in
diesem Jahr die Gas- und
strompreisbremse noch einführen und
Planungssicherheit für die Unternehmen
gewährleisten aktuell sind wir in der
Feinabstimmung mit der EU-Kommission
weil die Bremsen dem europäischen
Beihilferecht genügen und mindestens bis
Ende 2023 gelten müssen denn das will
ich noch mal ganz deutlich sagen wenn
sich die Speicher nach diesem Winter
lernen müssen wir diese mit alternativen
Gasquellen schnell wieder füllen gerade
deswegen ist das Sparen so wichtig und
wir müssen an die Ursache der Krise ran
an die Abhängigkeit von fossiler Energie
wir dürfen uns keine zwei Jahre Pause
als Volkswirtschaft leisten die
dekarbonisierung auch als
Wettbewerbsvorteil unsere Wirtschaft
muss weitergehen dafür brauchen die
Unternehmen Planungssicherheit bei den
Betriebskosten und eine Unterstützung
bei den Investitionen in der
Transformation das ist entscheidend dass
wir diese nächsten zwei Jahre auch dafür
weiter nutzen
zum Schluss sage ich nochmal in aller
Deutlichkeit bei der Auswahl das Paketes
werden wir sehr darauf achten dass der
Mittelstand nicht schlechter behandelt
wird als sie Industrie das ist mein Ziel
ich danke daher für die Unterstützung
dieses wichtigen Vorhabens
Michael Kellner ist parlamentarischer
Staatssekretär beim Bundesminister für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz und er bei
der vorletzte Redner in dieser Debatte
im Volk jetzt nur noch in
Anführungszeichen Kevin Kühnert da ja
spd-generalsekretär ist aber auch
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Bauen Wohnen
und Stadtentwicklung
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren im
Vorfeld dieser Debatte wo wir über den
WSF sprechen habe ich noch mal Ihnen die
Protokolle des Deutschen Bundestages
geschaut und wir nochmal zu
vergegenwärtigen wie das eigentlich
aussah als vor zweieinhalb Jahren der
WSF damals unter den frisch aufkommenden
Bedingungen der corona-pandemie auf dem
Weg gebracht wurden und das ist ganz
erstaunlich was man für Zitate in der
damaligen plenar-debatte zu diesem Thema
finden kann vielleicht einfach einen
kleinen Ausschnitt dazu mal hier
präsentiert damit sie ein Gefühl dafür
kriegen wir relativ manche
Wertevorstellungen von einigen hier im
Haus anscheinend sind damals wurde an
diesem Pult zum Beispiel geäußert es
gibt Situationen da muss man vielleicht
auch Entscheidungen treffen deren
Wirkung man nicht bis zum langen Ende
Bedenken und sehen kann aber man muss
Entscheidungen treffen um in der
Situation der größten Not diese zu
bekämpfen das hat ja damalige
Wirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier CDU
hier im Plenum gesagt und ihr damaliger
Fraktionsvorsitzender Herr Brinkhaus
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
der sagte folgendes wir werden in dieser
Krise liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
auch entscheiden denn das Schlimmste
dass man einer Krise machen kann ist
sich wegzuducken und nichts zu tun zu
warten bis der Sturm vorübergeht weise
Worte weise Worte die Herr Brinkhaus
damals gesprochen hat aber die die sich
heute in einer vergleichbaren Situation
der Krise und mit genau diesem
Instrument vor Augen leider nicht mehr
so recht erinnern wollen und es geht
noch weiter sie haben damals großherzig
in der Debatte im Deutschen Bundestag
den damaligen demokratischen
Oppositionsfraktion Grünen und FDP dafür
gedankt dass sie trotz seiner unklaren
Gemengelage in der nicht bis ins letzte
Detail schon alles entschieden war ihre
staatspolitische Verantwortung auch in
der Opposition wahrgenommen haben und
eingelöst haben dass die demokratische
Mehrheit zusammensteht warum sind sie
heute eigentlich nicht zur selben
staatsmännischen und freundlichen Tat
fähig meine Damen und Herren
stattdessen verstecken sie sich hinter
ziemlich fadenscheinigen Argumenten 200
Milliarden Euro aber man wisse ja gar
nicht so genau wofür das eigentlich
aufgewendet werden soll sagen sie das
eigentlich auch ihren sechs
Ministerpräsidenten die in der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz unter Punkt
4 genau dafür ihre Zustimmung gegeben
haben unter der Nennung von 200
Milliarden Euro als Rahmen für die
Kredit Ermächtigung steht dort in
einzelnen bulletpoints sie können das
alles nachlesen wofür genau das am Ende
gedacht ist zur Implementierung einer
gaspreisbremse für den Grundbedarf und
für die Industrie in Deutschland zur
Absicherung und zwar kurzfristig der
strompreisbremse in Deutschland für die
Liquiditätshilfen von Betrieben gerade
energieintensiven in Deutschland und
vielem anderen mehr da steht das drin
das hat ihren Ministerpräsidenten
gereicht um zu sagen jawoll dahinter
versammeln wir uns und vielleicht ist
das einfach der Unterschied zwischen
Leuten die Verantwortung tragen in dem
Land und Leuten die es jetzt einfach mal
ganz nett finden aus Position ein
bisschen krakehlen zu können
in ihrem Entschließungsantrag den ich
sehr genau gelesen habe steht drin mit
vollen Händen würde das Geld jetzt hier
ausgegeben werden
übermäßige haushaltspolster liege die
Regierung hier an es ist eine
verräterische Sprache die da zum
Ausdruck kommt denn übermäßige
haushaltspolster unterstellt nicht wer
vielleicht noch ein paar Detailfragen
hat zur genauen Umsetzung sondern
übermäßige haushaltspolster unterstellt
jemand der findet dass das einfach eine
unangemessen große Hausnummer ist über
die wir hier sprechen das wäre aber eine
spannende Einschätzung in Zeiten indem
BDI und andere davon ausgehen dass wir
vielleicht noch viel mehr brauchen
werden in den nächsten Jahren um die
Volkswirtschaft in Deutschland und die
Gesellschaft durch diese Krise
durchbekommen zu können sie klettern ja
schon am Anfang der Krise
sehen Sie es ist das gute Recht der
demokratischen Opposition die
Regierungskoalition zu kritisieren
Ungeduld zum Ausdruck zu bringen und
auch harte Fragen zu stellen es ist auch
das gute Recht der demokratischen
Opposition dabei keine wirklich
greifbaren eigenen Pläne vorzulegen wenn
wir auch heute in der Debatte noch mal
gemerkt haben wir erwarten aber von den
demokratischen Opposition auch Klarheit
und Wahrheit darüber wo sie eigentlich
selbst in dieser Debatte steht und dazu
gehört dass man nicht behauptet aus
politisch handwerklichen Gründen heute
nicht zuzustimmen wenn man eigentlich
aus politisch taktischen Gründen nicht
zustimmen will sie wollen heute
sie wollen heute aus politisch
taktischen Gründen nicht zustimmen weil
die nächsten Monate schwierig und
ungewiss werden und sie dann lieber
keinen Risiko eingehen stehen sie doch
einfach dazu und schreiben Sie dann
nicht in ihren Entschließungsantrag es
braucht eine pragmatische Politik die
das Wohl des Landes über wahl- und
parteitaktische Fragen stellt diesem
Anspruch wenn sie leider heute selbst
nicht gerecht das erledigt die Koalition
für Sie und da schreiten wir jetzt auch
zur Tat und stimmen zu ich danke Ihnen
recht herzlich